Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P Here is a call,
a very concise and pithy question.
Speaker 3: Hey, David, declared Republican
candidate. Who is the most reasonable candidate,
in your opinion? Thanks for all you do that.
Speaker 1: It's Chris Christie. As we talked
about earlier, it's so obvious who is the most
reasonable Republican candidate. It is Chris
Christie, a relatively moderate former governor
from New Jersey who understands the reality that
to get the Republican nomination, you have to
go through Trump. Yes, he is a self-aggrandizing
sort of guy, but is at least willing to admit some
mistakes, as he did during yesterday's town hall
event. He understands, even if I disagree with
him, on the solutions, he understands issues in
a far deeper way than many of these other people
that are running. And that is probably why he's
polling 1%, at least right now. He just announced
we don't have any announced any polling from after
Christie's announcement. It'll be interesting to
see in 10 to 14 days whether the polling moves
at all. He's polling 1% right now. If you came
to me and you said, David, the next president
will be one of these Republicans, it won't be
Joe Biden. It'll be one of these Republicans. Who
do you want to see as president? It is obviously
an undoubtedly Chris Christie from the current
slate of Republicans. If you disagree with me,
please let me know. We have a fantastic bonus show
for you today. Lying Congressman George Anthony
divulged there. Santos has lost his attempt to
shield the people who gave him his bail money.
He is no longer going to be able to keep
them secret. That is fascinating. Who
might they be? We will discuss. Oklahoma has
okayed its first religious charter school,
and this immediately is setting up a war over
separation of church and state because taxpayer
money is used for that charter school. And
a Texas sheriff is recommending criminal
charges over the Ron DeSantis migrant flight
stunt who would be charged and when and for
what crimes? We will tell you on the bonus
show sign up at join Pacman dot com. It is
the world famous and award winning bonus show.
Admittedly, they are all over. Words we give
out. But they are still great. I'll see you
then. You're back on the program tomorrow.